the U.S Secretary of Defense Lloyd
Austin has been speaking at a US Air
Base in Germany he's been talking about
the military training and support that
the U.S is providing to Ukraine
thanks Patrick
good afternoon everyone nearly one year
ago
I first convened what became the Ukraine
defense contact group right here
at the ramsden
our goal was to improve the coordination
of our support for Ukraine
as a fought back against Russia's
Reckless
and Lawless invasion
over the past year this contact group
has become
an extraordinary community of action
and together we have rallied to defend
the principles of democracy
and freedom
and sovereignty
so we're all back here at Ramstein a
year later
to build on that impressive progress
over the past year the members of this
contact group have provided tremendous
capability to Ukraine
right after Russia invaded
we surged in javelins and stingers
and then we provided Ukraine's Defenders
with howitzers
and high Mars
in other artillery
and we continue to rush in ground-based
air defense capabilities and Munitions
to help Ukraine control its Sovereign
Skies
and to help Ukraine defend its citizens
from
Russian cruise missiles and Iranian
drones
our Collective efforts have made a huge
difference on the battlefield
and now in just a few short months the
contact group has delivered
more than 230 tanks
more than 1 550 armored vehicles and
other equipment and munitions
to support more than nine new armored
brigades
we've also expedited our M1 Abrams
timelines to
Supply Ukraine with more armored
capability in the coming months
and the m1s that the ukrainians will use
for training
will arrive here in Germany in the next
few weeks
in all of this
is huge progress
and I am confident that this equipment
and the training that accompanied it it
will put Ukraine's forces in a position
to continue to succeed on the
battlefield
Ukraine's forces have
formidable capability and courage
as we've seen throughout
and all this progress rests on the
coordinated work of some 50 nations of
Goodwill
that have gathered
again today